let's go next - oh why don't we go to
John from Houston we haven't heard from
John from Houston since last year
actually what's going on John why David
hope all is well we're under some flash
flood warnings here in Houston so I'm
working remotely today all right be
careful I've been I've had this question
for you for a while and uh I've never
heard anyone talk about this so we know
that establishment Republican that went
into line behind or fell in line behind
Donald Trump me even after resistance
you know you have people like McConnell
and Paul Ryan you know speak out against
Donald Trump and then you know even
Lindsey Graham but eventually they all
fell in line now I'm wondering what your
thoughts are in terms of a progressive
if one of the progressive candidates
wins the general election
say Sanders or Warren do you think that
would happen with the Democrats do you
think they would fall in line behind the
present president and their progressive
ideas it'll depend on the issue so when
there are huge moneyed interests I think
for example you will probably see the
centrist wing of the Democratic Party
that is very well funded by insurance
companies for example they probably are
not going to be fully on board with
something like a president Bernie doing
Medicare for all I think on a lot of
other issues including geopolitical
issues and social issues you will see
the Democratic Party basically get
behind whoever of the people that are
remaining that have a shot at this thing
I think you will see them quite quite
United but I do think that on the issues
that are most connected to the moneyed
interests maybe telecommunications would
be another one potentially Big Pharma I
think you are going to see some
resistance from the centrist wing of the
Democratic Party if we do end up with a
progressive president yeah it's it's
unfortunate that you know we
that to look ahead to either yeah then
with the progressive president but you
know it's then they yeah I agree there
may be some resistance but that I guess
the crops whenever we get there the
other thing to remember John is that
from up from from 20 21 to 20 23 we are
going even with the Democratic president
we're still going to have a
republican-controlled Senate again if
people disagree with me you can let me
know why but I don't see any path to
Democrats taking over the Senate in 2020
so during those first two years a lot of
the big progressive ideas are not really
going to have a shot anyway because of
Republicans in the Senate and so then
the question will be what kind of what
kind of agreement can democrats build
from 20 21 to 20 23 so that if in the
2022 midterms democrats take over the
Senate then we're really ready to go
forward and that may be an interim
period during which consensus could be
built I don't know I'm thinking out loud
here well no I mean fortunately I mean
happen but a lot of what Tom's done has
been through executive order right so
also I guess and that's another question
all of the executive orders that that
Donald Trump is this signed would it be
just a stroke of a pen to undo with the
different president I believe that there
are some exceptions because there are
certain things you can use an executive
order to codify something elsewhere and
then I believe it becomes a little bit
more of a process to undo it but there
is a lot of what Trump has done by
executive order which could absolutely
be undone by executive order yes
absolutely fantastic well signed up for
a membership my family my sister's for
the holidays thank you so much John
really appreciate your support and great
to hear from you again all right take
care